during the reading for Wolf of Wall
Street you basically assaulted one of
the Premier actors of our time I I
thought I was going to get arrested I
walked in for the audition and Ellen
Lewis who was the casting director what
are you wearing I was like my clothes
she was like no no honey you're gonna go
downstairs you're going to walk into
Soho you're going to buy the highest
pair of heels you can find and the
tighter stress and then you're going to
come back and do the audition and I did
we did uh an audition scene we did the
seat where she wakes him up brother
rudely with the glass of water can we
help you piece of [__] we're improvising
and I got a bit caught up in the moment
and it wasn't scripted but you know I
was screaming at him and who's Venice
and I um I hit him in the face and I
thought I'd blown it I'm walking out I
take off my heels because my feet are
killing me Ellen Lewis is like quick pop
your head back in you guys want to see
you quickly and they were both sitting
there like this
and she came in and just she knocked it
out she really did him and Maddie were
like that was great you should do that
again
we'd like to either wrong